Senator John Kennedy is a publican
representing the state of Louisiana he
joins us tonight thanks so much for
coming on you bet the president will be
marked for all time this is indelible
this mark of impeachment the mark of the
beast what's your assessment of that
claim well I think the Senate is going
to have something to say about this you
you don't have to be mince some material
Tucker to see that speaker Pelosi is
swollen with partisan rage and the whole
process and the house was rigged we're
going to do it differently in the Senate
we're gonna treat both sides fairly as I
said the other day when we're done I I
don't want the American people to look
at the sentence work and say well we
just got run over by the same truck
twice it was unfair in the house and it
was unfair in the Senate I want people
to walk away and say look the Senate was
fair they did it right they gave you
some time to to both sides and we
understand the allegations and the
Senate voted and that's what we're going
to try to do if probably unknowable at
this stage but what do you expect the
time line roughly to be okay I think
there will be there'll be a presentation
first by the prosecution and there's
been a lot of talk about what witnesses
I realize that that common sense is
illegal in Washington but common sense
would tell you the discussion of
witnesses is premature we don't know the
senator is anyway we don't know the
details of the prosecution's case we
don't one of the details of President
Trump's defense because speaker Pelosi
didn't allow him to have one and in
terms of the prosecution's case if you
ask nine out of ten senators they'll
tell you they haven't read the
transcripts of the house and the tenth
is lying all they have done is look at
the news articles and their reading of
the media reports and as we know after
the reporting on the steel dust yeah you
have to be careful what you read so we
need to get we need
the prosecution and then we need to hear
the defense I think that will take
probably four days together then the
Senators can ask questions that'll take
a couple of days I'll learn a lot from
listening to the questions I'll learn a
lot from listening to the answers and
then after we actually maybe possibly
know what we're talking about we can
make a decision about witnesses now I
want to be fair about the witnesses if
we end up calling Chuck Schumer's
witnesses or the the prosecuting speaker
Pelosi's witnesses I think the speaker
and and Senator Schumer together on it I
want to treat the defense fairly the
president gets to call witnesses to yeah
everybody ever everybody gets some level
playing field and we could end up in a
very odd circumstance where Senator
Schumer he caught the car I mean he he
asked for his witnesses they're all
White House aides the president claims
executive privilege in fairness the
president gets his witnesses so we end
up hearing from Hunter Biden Joe Biden
whoever else is on the witness list yeah
a chairman when any of the chairmen that
were involved and the the prosecution
doesn't get to hear its witnesses
because of executive privilege well that
I mean that sounds fair to me we'll see
senator thanks so much now you got me
excited for what you be seated